- [Narrator] So I really
like to snack and one
of my most favorite snacks
of all time happens to be bananas.
I mean, you can have them in a smoothie,
with some peanut butter, on
some toast, in any way, really.
And usually like most people,
I just throw away the peels
after I'm done eating,
but did you know that banana peels
and leaves can be used to
make all kinds of things now?
In fact, since over 100 billion bananas
are consumed annually around the world,
scientists have developed technologies
that convert banana peels and leaves
into useful materials that
are also bio-degradable.
For example, bananas can
be used to make shoe soles,
which is truly mind blowing.
So a designer named Sarah
Harbarth used banana peel waste
to create a durable material
called Kouri, K-U-O-R-I,
which is used for everything
from glasses, to belts,
and even phone cases and shoe soles.
Banana leaves are also
used for making things
like disposable tableware or containers.
So in 2010, a young inventor
named Tenith Adithyaa saw
how banana leaves were going to waste
and developed a technology that
would preserve banana leaves
for up to three years.
And these could also be used
to create biodegradable containers.
So you're probably
wondering why I'm rambling
so much about bananas
and as much as I love them as a snack,
I personally think that
it's even more awesome
that scientists and engineers
are creating useful, biodegradable
materials out of them.
Technologies like Sarah and Tenith's
that help reduce plastic
waste are super great
for our planet and its biodiversity
because they prevent
more plastic microfibers
from polluting our environment.
And that's the great news.
With science and engineering,
we humans can create technologies
that prevent ecosystem degradation,
reduce pollution and
improve sustainability.
So let's take a look at a couple
of other really cool examples.
Since I live in the sunny all
year long state of Arizona,
it's not uncommon to
see residents making use
of solar panels here.
So this kind of technology
was created to allow photons,
or light particles, to
generate a flow of electricity.
And since it harnesses
energy from the sun,
this kind of electricity doesn't
require using fossil fuels.
So this means that solar panels help limit
greenhouse gas emissions, which contribute
to global warming and pose a threat
to the biodiversity
present on earth right now.
And even cooler for people
who want a more sleek option
to use for their homes,
we now have this thing
called solar roof tiles.
So these are roof tiles
that generate solar energy
and isn't that so cool?
Well technologies like this
will only continue improving,
which will help us combat climate change
and preserve biodiversity.
Now, if we drive westwards from Arizona
to California, the chances are you'll spot
these huge white
windmills lining the Hills
and windmills are another
source of clean energy.
They are designed to harness wind
and convert it to electricity.
So windmills function in a
similar way to solar panels.
thanks to the people who designed them,
we have another alternative
to fossil fuels,
which is super great for our planet.
And I could go on and on about all
of the amazing new technology
that's being created
to protect the environment.
Even now people are developing things
like eco-friendly vehicles,
buildings, household devices,
even waste management systems.
And as you can probably tell from all
of these unique technologies,
scientists and engineers
have already found
many different solutions to try
and address environmental issues.
But we also have to ask,
"Are there any drawbacks to all
of these new contributions?"
Well, there are some cons
that we have to consider.
For instance, since these
environmental friendly
technologies, or green
technologies are still
relatively new ideas, we have to do a lot
of research on them to make sure that
the technology can make
a significant impact
and succeed, and that we minimize
the environmental impacts that
these technologies can have.
So for example, solar panels
can take up a lot of space
and impact sensitive habitats.
So we need to research ways
to mitigate these effects.
So this requires large amounts of money
to be spent on researching
and developing these technologies,
which means that companies
may be less willing to switch
and pay so much for green alternatives.
And the high implementation
costs also means
that at first consumers like you
and me will probably
have to pay higher prices
for these technologies compared
to traditional products.
Going back to our
discussion on solar panels,
the drawback to installing panels
at home is usually a higher price.
So even though solar panels
would save homeowners money
in the long run on electricity,
some consumers might not be willing
or able to pay for the
higher initial price.
And last but not least,
some people who work
in conventional industries may go out
of business or lose their jobs.
So in order for the world to go greener,
we have to figure out ways
to protect these workers
and businesses as well.
So clearly there are many
challenges that we have
to address if we want
to implement technology
that's better for the environment,
but there's plenty of pros
to, seeing how scientists
and engineers can do so
much for the environment.
With science and
engineering we can come up
with methods to save
energy, reduce pollution,
conserve our planet's precious resources,
even feed more people
and also create new business
opportunities and jobs for people.
And that's the great thing.
Scientists and engineers and thinkers
around the world can use our existing pool
of knowledge to address some
of the biggest issues of today.
So to wrap up this video, today we learned
that scientists and
engineers can find solutions
to preserve the environment and make way
for a better future.
So the next time you have a banana,
or any fruit for that
matter, spot solar panels
or a drive by some windmills,
I hope you can reflect on the fact
that these green
innovations start as ideas.
So if you ever have an
idea for a technology
that you think can help our environment,
you should write it down.
It just might be useful one day.